[Music]
Conan O'Brien here with another clueless
gamer this one's very exciting the good
folks at Square Enix have asked me to
rate hitman absolution I don't play
games I'm not good at them I'm not even
very interested in them and yet I'm
being asked by a company to rate their
greatest gaming product a mistake for
them and a waste of time for me let's
begin
Aaron bleh art here hi Aaron hello how
are you Aaron what is your title on the
show I've never known I don't know web
guy okay
web guy tell us a little bit about
hitman absolution this game is awesome
it's the fifth one in the hitman fridge
I will decide whether it's alright to
begin the game has not even started yet
there's a lot of different scenes going
by and then there's a very attractive
nude woman in the shower why are we
seeing that and how do we make it just
be that I don't know that's part of the
game I think if that's the game I'm all
ready to play
listen to me so this takes place in
Chicago you work for a company that puts
contracts out on people to kill them
that's you
I am ripped if I had that body I would
never put a shirt on okay looking
himself in the mirror the barcode on the
back of the head isn't that a bit of a
giveaway why does he have that when does
it go off when he goes to like 7-eleven
but you said this with Chicago yeah I
guess there's been an earthquake in this
world and Chicago shifted to Tahiti now
we're following an ice cream truck
that's you in the ice cream truck who's
this guy that's louis c.k sad cameo from
Louie he's the hottest comic in the
country and they've got him working a
gate at an ice cream factory
Oh prologue this is the hell was that
all right here we go try to kill with
discretion and try to remain undetected
undetected I have a barcode on the back
of my bald head whoa I just did you see
that rule I just did yeah you can roll
back if you want
yeah excellent slip past while the guard
is distracted okay now we're gonna sneak
up on him oh no no faster oh god I want
to tell him I just killed that guy right
yeah I kill him yeah you killed it too
look drag I got to drag him somewhere
yeah or it's just a drag to have to kill
some
what do you mean by that they just leave
him someplace yeah you can leave them in
the weeds or you could put them in like
a bin you want to put them in a bin yeah
what's a hide him you know what is there
a recycling here
yeah yeah that would be more responsible
low back the body is now hidden now you
can get in that bin if you want like I
so much chasing you oh I thought you
just wanted me to get in with the body
you look creep you can get in there if
you want
necrophilia hit man
aim for the head then increase your
precision by steadying your aim there is
right there see watch this headshot oh
jeez wait let's take a whole lot trigger
okay here we go check out his body and
you probably want to like put it in a
sleeping bag and cuddle with it the
situation has been contained you know
what's great about this property lots of
body storage
tight-ass can you play tennis no
something must have gotten her spooked
can I shoot him nipple no we're gonna
strangling know God just x2 oh geez
don't get in front of him pretty sneak
up a funny guy I think that's Cara Lee I
like to strangle someone No
okay where are we taking him now drag
him back to the video on I ain't you
have to say I'm very tidy as killers go
boom cleans up better than I do I spent
most the game like tidying Murray gonna
put them in a bin and you can leave them
in you know what I'm tired of cleaning
up let's go guys such a neatnik it's
okay what do we work to now alright
sort of the next level it killed as much
as we can kill all right this is called
shaving Lenny see where it's small-town
South Dakota I like this car I'm driving
look bunch of Punk's everywhere oh my
god it's the it's the cast of grease hey
where's Rizzo
targets the two guys are right up there
in front of you you can just kill those
dudes by blowing up that car
aim at the car aim at the car
aim at the car in that car where the car
okay now I gotta get out of here - yeah
I'll be killed - the dudes can I use
this ATM I'm just like having cash now
we're at another level what's going on
Blaine okay so this is the bad guy
Travis he's after you we found him okay
this is Nick Offerman right can't take
him seriously what's wrong with his hand
oh he's got a metal robot hands
impressive that he still chooses to wear
a tie when he's got a prosthetic hand
just kill turtleneck in your life is 40%
easier basically now your agency is
trying to kill you they've sent out
their top hit squad called the Saints
Yeah right the Saints they're a bunch of
assassin nuns I will be good at this
level I was raised Catholic I had it I
went to Catholic school for a while and
they did try to kill me
this little starts the Saints have just
blown up your hotel room but why am i
wearing a woman's silk spa robe cuz I
had a spa when they attacked that barely
covers my junk that road
the nuns over there so yeah those three
nuns at the top are your targets so now
go across the road we're gonna get into
a disguise that's gonna help us
so that's scarecrow that's we're gonna
go Quinn addresses his scarecrow yeah
look at him he's so emasculated in this
robe and now he's gonna dress as a
scarecrow right so now hey give it up 47
Oh anyway there's a guy right next to us
I think we should be quiet we have a
hula girl statue we can bring them with
we have a hula girl stash no we just we
had it from the what's not the gun we
have the gun I don't but they can hear
the gun
this guy's blown well now they know that
there's a scarecrow killing people yeah
but didn't they always know that then we
here dragged this guy this guy's body
right there it's guys gonna have
incredible low back problems late in
life
yes dump them in there again incredible
amount of story right everywhere and I
hate why get why oh we just lost him
oh that's not gonna make any noise
that's fantastic they know everyone
there he's gonna get murdered we got a
casualty but no visual on possible
target you know why cuz I'm a scarecrow
in a cornfield mother
idiots there's something going on we
mean I've heard nine guys get killed and
someone's been using the body mulcher
anything out there well there's a
scarecrow killing everyone but that
couldn't be him well you know if there's
a nun on the right you want to kill one
of the nuns you bet yeah she's right
there right there see it just walk there
she sleep getting nuns to become a bad
habit house we have grated mini game so
far hitman absolution maybe my favorite
Wow I'll be honest with you I'll do a
scale using colors green being good dark
red being bad yellow being excellent and
sort of an okra being poor I would say
that this is an aquamarine hitman
absolution I'm very excited
with polish playing this game in the
future you all know that's not bad
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]